Riding. Listen, always faceless
lines and abstract symmetry.
Originally it was a bunch of pictures.
Come see how it all started.
It's 17,000 years ago.
It's cold out and getting colder.
Possibly dangerous too.
This may be France and this
may be the history of writing,
but there's nothing for you here until
you take shelter in a nearby cave and see
how creative some of your ancestors
really were drawing on their enlarging
brains and a long prehistory of
building evermore complex tools.
These early artists took to etching
and painting beautiful visual
representations of the animals
around them. These aren't words,
they're not stories.
They're pictures. Early.
Pictures like these start
to become very routine,
not necessarily depicting the world,
but marking and standing for things.
A place to hunt,
a place to eat.
These are pictographs.
The story gets sketchy here,
but it's important to notice
that pictographic symbols
like these Petroglyphs,
rock carvings weren't words.
They weren't language,
but they became more than personal
and communal artistic expressions.
They became regular and repeatable,
possibly mapping to specific things
and for that these pictographs earned
themselves.
The fancy label of Prodo riding.
Many pictographs have an
intuitive giveaway quality.
They look like drawings of the things
they represent. Draw me a human easy.
Draw me a horse. Sure.
A river. There it is,
but how do you clearly and simply draw
less tangible ideas like playing around
or taking it easy or don't
even think about it. Uh Oh,
watch out for this major moments in
the history of writing meet metonymy.
This principled fellow lets you represent
a general nebulous idea with the
related pictogram or part of a pictogram
or a pictogram combo that's pretty
specific and obvious. Ancient stick
human is a regular old pictogram.
If you cut off sticks legs,
you can get across the general
idea of what walking, removing.
What about a man leaning against a tree?
What's the idea here?
Taking it easy. Resting.
These are idiot graphs,
symbols for ideas and concepts.
In some sense.
All of these drawings express ideas.
The concept of a horse,
the concept of a human,
so they're all idiographic but with a
little imagination and a lot of time
extended idiot graphs that you've cut
and combined basic pictographs to be far
more expressive and abstract.
Just when you're ready to grab that
Chisel and get your pictographic and
idiographic carving on someone more
inventive than you comes along.
Your pictures and ideas aren't enough
for her. Gone are the old cave days,
the world outside changing and
she needs words, words. My friend.